recently he started really going after
Islam yeah why did he do that
well I catch a total turn in another
direction there are two theories about
this and I don't know which is right or
maybe neither but the two I've heard one
is there's a whole school thought that
emphasizes that Alex Jones has always
been kind of covering up for you
I looked into 9/11 closer after hearing
that David Ray Griffin was working on it
and saying it was an inside job and so I
looked at that evidence and was
convinced and realized that this was so
important that it was worth pursuing and
so I've been jumping down all the rabbit
holes ever since
another and I think possibly more
plausible reason that Alex Jones would
have gone down this crazy path of
extreme Islamic phobia even though he
knows 9/11 was an inside job is that he
makes more money that way yeah you're
right that if any of us who've actually
looked into Islam and seen this
completely different picture the reality
of Islam which as you say it's it's the
best preserved authentic tradition of be
but as soon as you express yourself you
ask questions you lose your job yeah
that's right and we have some why some
of the top will come the top six why's
that have to do with what we're talking
about because that was a catalyst is
evil event that Islam condemns Muslims
condemned 9/11 and we're going to be
asking the six wives with our special
guests here dr. Kevin when we come back
double anyway